if you look at the modern map of Europe
you'll see a curious exclave along the
Baltic Sea
this is Kaliningrad and has been a part
of the Russian Federation since 1991 the
more observant of you will have noticed
that it isn't attached to Russia which
raises the question why does Russia own
Kaliningrad and how did it come to
possess it well first of all the region
centered on a city of the same name
hasn't been known as Kaliningrad for
very long but prior to this was known as
Konigsberg from the 13th century it was
a part of the lands of the Teutonic
order and by the 16th century
Koenigsberg was the central part of the
newly formed duchy of prussia a puppet
state of the Polish Lithuanian
Commonwealth
it wasn't long before Prussia broke free
in königsberg was the site which showed
the first King of Prussia crowned within
a few centuries it had grown to this and
by the late 19th century was the
dominant force within the newly formed
German Empire as you'll be able to guess
Konigsberg whilst not the capital held a
special place within the German Empire
as one of its cultural centres in the
birthplace of its ruling dynasty the
point I'm trying to get at is for about
six centuries prior to this point
Konigsberg and its surrounding area was
primarily German although you should
note that there were sizeable Polish and
Lithuania minorities there too the
status of this land didn't really change
until the Second World War although you
should be aware that the 1919 Treaty of
Versailles after the first world war
tore Germany lose this territory in its
ruling Prussian dynasty as you'll notice
it did keep her nice Berg itself but
this time as its own exclave known as
eastern prussia you'll also notice that
it did lose this land to the newly
formed Lithuania which throughout the
period of the Vimal republic was a
hotbed of support that a growing
national socialist movement which soon
saw us as an adult Hitler running the
show he got this land back from
Lithuania and also QED World War Two
which Germany lost in 1945 Soviet forces
advanced on Konigsberg and this led to
many of the people living there fleeing
west deeper into Germany after a
destructive siege the city fell to the
Soviets and after Germany surrender its
borders were once again redrawn by the
victorious powers this time Germany was
to lose Konigsberg in the area around it
to Stalin to USSR and it's no Eastern
European puppet States the region of
East Prussia was thus divided into three
parts
the southern part went to Poland and the
northern part went to the USSR but as a
part of the Lithuanian Soviet republic
and as for the center which included the
city of königsberg itself this went to
the USSR's Russian Soviet republic so
why wasn't it given to Lithuania despite
being next door well at this point
Lithuania had only recently been
incorporated into
the USSR mostly it's the will of those
who lived there and thus Stalin didn't
trust them with an area of such military
importance furthermore the region was
subject to widespread ethnic cleansing
which saw most of its remaining Germans
deported to East Germany and replaced
mostly with Russians that said when
Stalin died his successor Nikita
Khrushchev did offer Kaliningrad to
Lithuania who said no why because the
people there weren't Lithuanian and its
leaders felt that incorporating so many
Russians into its territory would cause
long-term issues thus Kaliningrad would
remain a part of the Russian Soviet
republic throughout the lifespan of the
USSR until its collapse in 1991 they
smoked a point in which the status of
the area could have changed Lithuania
still wasn't interested in Kaliningrad
for the same reasons as before and this
view was shared by Poland that left
Germany which had a long-standing
historical claim to the area so why
didn't they get it first of all it was
because the Russian Federation inherited
the lands of the Russian Soviet republic
and also because Germany didn't want it
during the process of reunification the
West German Chancellor Helmut Kohl
didn't push to regain the exclave his
first priority was the reunification of
East and West and he felt that trying to
force the issue of Kaliningrad would
upset the global powers he was trying to
negotiate with Britain and France were
already wary of a reunified Germany and
to give it extra land was to them a
cause for yet more concern and so
Germany never tried to reclaim
konigsberg which was barely even German
anymore and for Russia
Kaliningrad was just as Russian as any
other bit of it and so why would they
even contemplate letting it go I hope
you enjoyed this episode and thank you
for watching with extra thanks to my
patreon supporters which you can see on
screen and with an extra special thanks
to James Bissonnette David archaeologist
Ozark a flash Party Boyko Rob Waterhouse
Chris wicker Michael Reynolds Gustav
Swann David Silverman spinning three
plates
Maggie packs Kowski Christian check'
Anthony Beckett Ike Skye Chappell and
Winston K word